We’ve all gotten lost in a
store before. It’s strange,
a little embarrassing, but
really nothing to worry about.
Unless the store you’ve gotten lost in is
SCP-3008, also known as The Infinite Ikea.
This cursed Ikea can be accessed through
a kind of portal in a particular but
unknown Ikea superstore. You can
wander through it without even knowing,
and then become hopelessly lost in a
maze of affordable Swedish appliances.
But it’s not just getting lost you have to worry
about. The infinite Ikea is filled with tall,
faceless, humanoid entities dressed in Ikea
uniforms. These monsters, referred to as
“The Staff”, begin hunting anyone still trapped
in the store when the lights go off at night.
Thankfully, you’ll at least have company. The
Infinite Ikea is a kind of nexus between the
Ikeas in a number of different dimensions.
So many people have become trapped in the
Ikea over the years that whole tribes
and communities have formed inside.
So you might as well make some friends and
enjoy some meatballs until you can escape!